on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 10 mars
confinement prolonger ce week-end dans
les alpes-maritimes toujours pas à
l'ordre du jour en ile de france le
porte parole du gouvernement qui a tenu
son habituel point presse alors qu'un
mouvement d'occupation des théâtres
s'est accélérée aujourd'hui dans le pays
pour réclamer la réouverture des lieux
culturels
côté vaccination l'objectif de 10
millions de vaccinés d'ici semaine
prochaine est toujours possible selon
gabriel attal royaume uni 20 2 millions
de britanniques ont déjà reçu la
première dose du vaccin en tic au vide
résultat entre autres de la stratégie de
boris johnson si le premier ministre
était critiqué au début pour sa gestion
de la crise sanitaire et son pari raté
l'immunité collective il dame
aujourd'hui le pion à l'union européenne
qui peine toujours à obtenir des doses
et accélérer la cadence de la
vaccination
faut-il dissoudre le conseil national de
l'ordre des médecins la réponse est oui
pour plusieurs syndicats de médecins et
associations de patients
dans une tribune publiée en ligne 26 ans
et lisa sion évoque une instance
déontologiques qui protège des
professionnels ne sont et corrompu et
maltraitant et qui est jugée inutile et
nocive présenté comme indispensable
l'ordre elle est il vraiment ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
la léonce revient en force joe biden
participera vendredi à une réunion
virtuelle avec les dirigeants
australiens indiens et japonais dans le
cadre du dialogue quadri latéral pour la
sécurité au menu des discussions le
changement climatique et la pandémie de
kovy priorités du président américain
en toile de fond entre autres objectifs
contre balancer la puissance chinoise
[Musique]
pas d'évolution de prévu après le
conseil de défense sanitaire de ce matin
à l'elysée au programme de ce désormais
traditionnel rendez-vous
interministériel du mercredi un point
sur la situation dans les 23
départements placés sous surveillance
renforcée en raison de la flambée de
nouveau quatre copies de 19 notamment
les alpes maritimes à ne veut confiner
ce week end
gabriella talent qui essaie lui les
efforts consentis par les habitants du
département
il mesure difficile très difficile qui a
été prise c'est notamment la mise en
place d'un confinement le week-end et
moi la première chose que je veux faire
c'est salué la mobilisation et les
efforts colossaux qui ont été consentis
par les habitants des alpes-maritimes
on a vu ces deux dernières semaines que
cette règle était respecté ces mesures
puisque il y en avait d'autres autour
produisent des effets le taux
d'incidence a baissé je crois de l'ordre
de 22% en une semaine dans les alpes
maritimes
ce qui montre que ces mesures qui ont
été décidées après concertation au
niveau local ont des effets dans les
alpes-maritimes et la culture
s'impatiente plusieurs centaines de
personnes devant le théâtre de l'odéon
cet après midi à paris un rassemblement
des acteurs du monde du spectacle pour
protester contre la fermeture des lieux
culturels
ils demandent notamment un
accompagnement pour la réouverture des
salles de spectacle et le prolongement
de l'année blanche écouter justement ces
deux comédiens qui était cet après midi
devant peut-être on vient de subir un
nom de fermeture des théâtres donc on
est dans une situation où la france n'a
plus accès à l'art à la culture les
musées sont fermés les théâtres sont
fermés c'est une chose qui devient
insupportable et pour nous qui sommes
des acteurs et actrices du de la culture
ou de l'art en france et en même temps
pour les spectateurs
je pense que si les artistes
ne parle pas il y a une majorité de la
population qui se sent pas soutenu
nous sommes porteurs de paroles et ce
qui a été terrible ces derniers mois
c'est qu'avec les lieux de culture fermé
il n'y a plus qu'une seule parole qui
est celle du média on continue et dans
ce contexte de pandémie l'ordre des
médecins dont le viseur de plusieurs
syndicats de médecins et associations de
patients
c'est dans une tribune publiée en ligne
hier que 26 organisations appellent à la
dissolution de cette instance
déontologiques qui selon elle protège
des professionnels de santé corrompu et
main traitants et a jugé inutile et
nocive l'ordre tentent de se justifier
réaffirme être au service des médecins
dont l'intérêt des patients à l'origine
des critiques notamment un rapport
accablant publié par la cour des comptes
en 2016 écoutez à ce sujet bernard
coadout signataires de cette tribune et
secrétaire général du mouvement de
soumission aux ordres professionnels
le rapport de la cour des comptes il
s'attaque à différents pas de l'activité
des médecins malversations financières
habib pouvoir favoritisme etc
mais où ça devient quand même très très
éclairant seller le traitement des
plantes à caractère sexuel ou les
agresseurs sont des médecins il y en a
une conclusion de la cour des comptes se
basant sur une douzaine de dossiers qui
est accablante et qui dit qu'il ya eu
l'ouverture de certains médecins
prédateurs sexuels
parlons des médecins et qui dans le même
temps négliger les plaintes des victimes
qu'elle soit la plupart du temps majeur
mais aussi mineur comme on va le revivre
avec le nouveau procès de la sphère joël
le scouarnec en dehors aussi d'aider
preuve d'agression sexuelle quand il
s'agit de maltraitance à enfants des
choses comme ça il ya une pédopsychiatre
à toulouse qui se voit interdite de
trois mois de l'exercer non là ça peut
plus durer
on ne sait pas quel sera tu alors
question faut-il vraiment dissoudre ce
conseil national de l'ordre des médecins
a présenté comme indispensable et qui
certes il est dans l'intérêt
qui c'est l'objet de notre face à face
ce soir bonsoir à claude bronner
médecins généralistes vice-président du
syndicat union des généralistes merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés fabrique sa
division avocat spécialiste en droit de
la santé bonsoir fabrice di vizio merci
également à vous d'être là on l'a vu ces
organisations qui juge cette instance à
un des ontologies qu inutiles et nocives
les mots sont assez forts dans une
tribune
donc ces associations demandent la
dissolution tout simplement du conseil
national de l'ordre des médecins ce
qu'ils ont raison est ce qu'il ya un
vrai problème avec l'ordre dr braun r il
ya un problème avec l'ordre comme avec
beaucoup d'institutions mais il ne faut
clairement à jeter le bébé avec l'eau du
bain et l ordre à des utilités
certainement beaucoup de situations il
permet notamment aux patients et aux
médecins de se retrouver quand ils ne
sont pas d'accord entre eux et la
différence première entre l'ordre et la
justice par exemple c'est que quand vous
portez plainte à l'ordre en tant que
patient vous serez à manca blement
entendu en face du médecin contre qui
vous vous plaignez et sam ne le ça se
passe pas du tout comme ça dans la
justice par exemple qui remplacerait
l'ordre si on était amené à le supprimer
alors je vois m division qui lève les
yeux au plafond d'ores et déjà avant de
me faire réagir
je vous propose d'écouter ses 26
associations et organisations
signataires de la tribune qui s'appuie
donc sur un rapport de la cour des
comptes publié fin 2010 9
voici ce que dit ce rapport l'ordre n'a
que marginalement tenu compte des
recommandations formulées par la cour en
l issue de son précédent contrôle il
reste marqué par des problèmes de
gouvernance de sérieuses défaillances de
gestion des insuffisances persistantes
dans l'exercice de ses missions et un
manque de rigueur dans le traitement des
plaintes et des patients l'ordre
intervient fréquemment dans le champ de
la défense des intérêts
national bank étant assis sur le rôle
des syndicats dans le même temps il
n'exerce qu'un parfaitement nombre de
ses missions comme le contrôle du
respect par les médecins de leurs
obligations de développement
professionnel continu ou des règles
déontologiques de la profession
souffrent de graves lacunes l'accès aux
soins n'apparaît pas non plus comme une
priorité
certains errements de gestion pourront
donner lieu à une saisine des autorités
judiciaires par l'intermédiaire du
parquet général près la cour des comptes
qui fait un bien l'entendre
de fait manifestement assez grave qui
indique en substance que lors de
n'exerce qu'un parfaitement nombre de
ses missions les mots sont durs fabrice
di vizio à quoi sert l'ordre des
médecins
je voulais déjà déniché à riom
rien sinon à emmerder les médecins met
fin voilà on l'a bien vu dans ce dans
cette crise
à quoi a servi l'an est ce que le dr
bronner c'est intéressant le top runners
à quoi a servi l'ordre aces qu'il a
servi à protéger les médecins
est ce que l'ordre à un moment ou à un
autre est monté au créneau pour dire
attention là on manque de tout est ce
que l'ordre un moment ou un autre s'est
érigé en protecteur des médecins n'ont
tout ce que l'ordre a fait dans cette
crise c'est en choisir quelques uns qui
l'arrangeait mais poursuivre évidemment
en fer grande publicité alors que
pendant ce temps là la cour des comptes
vous disait attention il ya des
problèmes sur vos missions et notamment
sur le contrôle des liens entre les
médecins l'industrie pharmaceutique fait
mais cela le lien entre l'industrie
pharmaceutique et les médecins là
curieusement l'ordre s'y est pas
intéressé dans cette crise c'est ça qui
est assez singulier si vous voulez et
entendre le dr bronner vous expliquez
que l'intérêt de l'ordre c'est de mettre
face à face les victimes après les
patients et les médecins mais j'espère
quand même que dire on n'a pas oublié
dans ce pays que la justice a précédé
l'ordre que l'ordre et mais il ya très
tardivement et que avant l'ordre
existait la justice et que d'autres
systèmes comme le système italien par
exemple a définitivement abandonné la
justice ordinale pour la confier aux
institutions judiciaires des droits
communs donc on est sur une espèce de
mille feuille administratif juridique
français qui à la spécialité de ce pays
et concrètement on a lu le patrimoine de
l'ordre on a vu large
dont dispose l'ordre mais finalement les
missions de l'ordre
concrètement je le redis mise à part
envers des médecins je sais pas quoi
hunter alors la réponse de club preneur
alors bien sûr que parfois l'ordre peut
emmerder les médecins comme le dit
fabrice di vizio
mais c'est aussi parce que tout
simplement les médecins ont failli et
que quelqu'un a porté plainte contre eux
en même temps il sert aussi à défendre
les patients alors dans le rapport de la
cour des comptes il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont parfaitement vrai bien
évidemment que l'ordre des médecins
auraient à se réformer et aurait à être
un petit peu moins dépensiers dans de
mauvaises dans une mauvaise direction
mais encore une fois il faut pas jeter
le bébé avec l'eau du bain
ce dont on parle dans le rapport de la
cour des comptes c'est pas ce qui se
passe dans tous les conseils
départementaux
c'est quelque chose qui est arrivé trop
souvent à mon goût
dans un certain nombre d'endroits ce
n'est pas parce qu'on n'est pas d'accord
avec une décision de justice et c'est
pas l'avocat que je vais le dire qu'on
va dire qu'il faut supprimer la justice
militaire donc la suppression de l'ordre
et quelque chose qui amènerait beaucoup
moins de deux sites de l'endroit où on
ne pourrait pas régler des problèmes
qu'on règle actuellement
moi je quand j'étais plus jeune j'étais
contre l'ordre comme le syndicat des
médecins généralistes et puis j'étais
conseiller ordinal quelques années et
j'ai compris à quoi ça servait et j'ai
moi personnellement porté plainte contre
mon président ordinale parce qu'il fait
partie de ceux qui ont été désignés par
la cour des comptes
je les fais mais ce n'est pas pour ça
que je suis contre pour la suppression
de l'ordre
alors messieurs tous les deux je vous
trouve assez doué c'est plutôt rare que
des sacs à brive sa division parce que
vous
ce sera rien il ya des petits
dysfonctionnements sauf que les 26 de
l'organisation là elles nous disent
c'est une instance qui protège des
professionnels de santé corrompu et
maltraitant on a entendu l intervenant
précédent bernard quad ou qu'ils nous
disaient voilà il ya des victimes qui se
plaignent de médecins la de prédateurs
sexuels
il le dit et l'indre a servi à protéger
les médecins alors vous dit fabrice les
mises division ça emmerde les médecins a
en l'occurrence la salle et protège
contre les faits finalement assez grave
le point sur lequel je peux pas ne pas
être d'accord avec toi preneur c'est
qu'il faut se méfier des caricatures
c'est à dire que si un sur ce que je
viens de dire désolé j'y viens c'est à
dire que lorsque vous exposer sur des
des dysfonctionnements tels que ça
protégerait les médecins vis-à-vis des
patients je vais vous dire moi ça fait
20 ans que je fais ce métier j'ai celle
inverse donc je ne plains c'est à dire
que je me plains d'une justice ordinale
qui a souvent tendance à taper taper
fort et taper un peu n'importe comment
hélas dans l'impartialité d'ailleurs des
remises en cause et j'ai souvent
l'impression d'une justice qui
finalement fonctionne pour faire simple
à la tête du client ou les règles ne
sont pas claires
on n'a pas ces garanties qu'on a devant
le juge de droit commun chasser clair si
vous voulez maintenant là où c'est
incontestable c'est que il ya un
problème avec l'ordre national des
médecins en particulier sur le fait que
corrompu
c'est un mot qui est fort si vous voulez
et moi j'ai pas l'habitude d'accuser les
gens sans preuve
je les ai jamais fait et ça maintenant
que je vais commencer j'ai pas traiter
l'ordre d'être corrompu parce que c'est
une accusation d'une particulière
gravité
ce que note la cour des comptes c'est
qu'il y a des problèmes majeurs qui
mérite effectivement d'être signalé au
parquet et d'un côté et aux autorités de
jugement de l'autre
bah je crois que c'est ça le vrai coeur
du problème c'est à dire que le vrai
problème que nous avons un corps
national des médecins aujourd'hui c'est
que nous avons une institution qui est
incapable de se réformer que soit la
venue en 2012 j'ai déjà eu des
avertissements
elle est incapable de se réformer et
toute la question c'est pourquoi
et à qui profite finalement ce
dysfonctionnement majeur à qui profite
il c'est ça la question de fond
braun r on va rappeler quand même que ce
fameux conseil de l'ordre a porté
plainte contre l'un des clients de m
division didier raoul tu décision
diversement apprécié d'ailleurs au sein
de la communauté médicale en pleine
épidémie coronavirus c'était selon voeux
seront une fan et qu'elles prennent un
petit peu de hauteur que le brodeur dans
cette affaire par exemple c'est son rôle
de porter plainte je ne je ne suis pas
sûr que c'était ce qu'il a fait de mieux
dans le contexte mais après tout didier
rahout quoi qu'en dise m di vizio a eu
des attitudes ac en teignant
déontologique il a quand même été
particulièrement agressif dans ses
propos et c'est sur le plan médical
on peut largement discutée
personnellement je n'aurais pas porté
plainte contre lui mais je ne suis pas
scandalisé du fait que l'ordre les faits
et c'est normal que m division qui
défend des médecins dit ce n'est pas
normal que l'ordre les attaques mais
c'est quand même son rôle et je dois
dire pour avoir fait pas mal de défense
des médecins aussi je dois bien dire que
l'ordre n'est de loin pas pire que la
justice avec les médecins comme comme
avec comme dans beaucoup d'autres
situations m division une réponse la
réponse c'est que c'est intéressant ce
que du moteur brodeur parce que moi j'ai
quand même une vraie difficulté dans
cette affaire je le redis c'est que les
liens entre les médecins et l'industrie
pharmaceutique est protégé son protégé
par l'ordre
c'est ça que dit la cour des comptes et
je suis étonné de la part d'un
conseiller ordinal ça vous fasse pas
bondir et est finalement parce que le
coeur de cette pandémie
le coeur du problème c'est que dans
cette épidémie finalement non seulement
l'ordre n'a rien fait pour protéger les
médecins mais finalement il à pyla il a
comment je vais dire crédibiliser une
parole qui était plein de liens et de
conflits d'intérêts et on commence à
comprendre à la lecture du rapport du
coroner cour des comptes que c'était
volontaire et que donc d'un côté on
poursuit sa route et vous avez raison il
moi je les dis sur cette antenne il a le
droit de le faire on en débattra devant
la chambre mais moi ce qui m'inquiète
c'est qu'il ya tout un tas de liens
d'intérêts de conflit d'intérêts qui
sont des ans qui sont énormes et que
l'ordre s'est bien gardé finalement de
dénoncer c'est ça qui fait que c'est
extrêmement grave et que du coup sa
parole est réduite à néant et que
finalement son rôle s'en trouve à caen
en plein coeur alors certains politiques
en tout cas rejoindre votre pensée en
maître division c'est le cas du
président des patriotes flux environ
finit pas écouter ce qu'ils pensent de
l'ordre des médecins ses médecins aux
raisons il est temps de dissoudre
l'ordre des médecins il s'est distingué
de façon détestable depuis le début de
cette crise qu vide en jouant
systématiquement le rôle de petit toutou
du gouvernement et des grands labos un
petit toutou du gouvernement et des
grands labos c'est pas flatteur que bob
renner c'est un peu sévère ce diagnostic
oui c'est bien sûr parfaitement sévère
l'ordre a fait son travail dans la crise
contrairement à ce qu'on dit il s'est
occupé les médecins il s'est occupé des
patients et il n'est pas à le toutou du
gouvernement c'est un organisme qui et
qui fait partie de la république il est
pas pire que les partis politiques à ce
niveau là moi je suis d'accord qu'il
aurait besoin de se réformer je suis
d'accord que l'ordre auraient besoin
d'être plus dynamique mais c'est avant
tout une structure qui est élu élu par
l'ensemble des médecins
c'est la seule structure en france qui
rassemble les médecins hospitaliers et
les médecins libéraux tout le reste est
séparée et c'est quand même un avantage
important donc bien sûr qu'il faut
réformer bien sûr qu'ils font parfois un
peu mou pas bien sûr qu'ils sont parfois
un peu vieux jeu mais ça reste non pas
une généralité mais quelque chose qui
reste locale et sur la problématique du
coc vide le l'ordre des médecins a va
jouer son rôle j'aurais pu faire mieux
mais il a joué son rôle d'être divisés
n'est pas d'accord allez-y répondez vite
parce que j'ai encore une dernière
question
que l'ordre des médecins dans ce qu bid
a joué son rôle pas excusez moi mais
rien que rien que son attitude dans ce
qu vide justifie sa dissolution
il n'a rien fait rien la question des
masques pour les soignants aujourd'hui
on a des médecins à l'hôpital compass 2
ffp2 et les hôpitaux sont devenus de
véritables kloster en partie à cause de
ça l'ordre a été fait villa absolument
pas réagi il n'a absolument jamais
porter la moindre parole publique hier
de protection des médecins et de jamais
tapé ne serait ce que du bout du pied le
gouvernement alors quand florian
philippot et dieu sait que ça me coûte
de dire que je suis d'accord avec lui
parle de tout ou du gouvernement je leur
ai pas dit dans ces termes mais et une
meilleure manière de le dire
ahoutou très riche 85 millions d'euros
de budget annuel notamment il suit des
cotisations obligatoires de quelque
trois cent mille médecins claude bronner
sided peut-être les appétits et les et
les malhonnêtetés vous savez vous qui
gère cette petite fortune eh bien oui ce
sont les élus de l'ordre tant au niveau
des départements qu'au niveau national
ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est une
somme importante qui n'est pas utilisée
aussi bien qu'elle devrait l'être mais
c'est notre argent à nous les médecins
il n'y a pas un centime de l'état qui
est donnée à l'ordre et donc on ne peut
pas dire que c'est géré de manière
malhonnête c'est géré tap runner sa cour
des comptes qui le dit écritures
comptables irrégulière un complexe voire
délibérément faussées
vous pouvez pas venir me dire que
l'ordre et gère honnêtement son argent
quand vous allez le public
izia izia 90 départements en france il y
en a combien qui sont désignés dans le
rapport de la cnaf dans le rapport de la
cour il nous parle de l'ordre national
des médecins ici ils vous parlent pas de
leurs départements tôt ils vous parlent
de l'ordre national si une part de
l'institution qui chapeaute le tout est
là et respecté par les icônes qui soude
c'est pas qu'il faut dissoudre les
ordres c'est ce qu'il faut dissoudre
l'ordre national une manière de la
présenter les choses qui est assez
spécieuse il faut bien de répondre
d'accord merci en tout cas à tous les
deux que le bonheur merci également
fabrice di vizio devant accepter ce
face-à-face merci à vous deux dans le
reste de la chronique dans le reste de
l'actualité une amende de 700 euros
requise contre le journaliste à boire ce
juge est aujourd'hui pour outrage et
rébellion envers un policier elle fr on
tord aux pointes 2019 les journalistes
avaient été interpellés alors qu'ils
filmaient une manifestation de sans
papiers elf en ville en région
parisienne j'ai aujourd'hui au tribunal
correctionnel de créteil taboye fsa
avait déposé plainte en assurant qu'un
officiel avait blessé à l'épaule écouter
d'intéresser et son avocat microdon
charles beaudry jus de mer a continué à
mentir
et à maintenir les procès verbaux malgré
les vidéo édifiante donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya une forme de raisonnement
totalitaires dans dans cette
présentation tant de monsieur de merck 2
j'ai l'air de police que de son avocat
que du ministère public qui a réclamé
une condamnation sur l'outragé mais pas
sur la rébellion on a l'impression de ne
pas avoir gardé la même vidéo ni de ne
pas avoir entendu les mêmes choses et
après effectivement un problème cognitif
dans cette histoire l'état voit ce qu'il
a envie de voir et
il crée sa propre vérité les
fonctionnaires de police également
j'ai été agressé par un policier de la
bac maxime demers j'ai écopé de dix
jours d'itt et et je dois me faire
opérer de l'épaule j'ai trois semaines
d'arrêt mais c'est moi qui me retrouve
depuis deux ans régulièrement tous les
deux mois les procédures envoyé sur le
banc des accusés est en tout cas c'est
sûr je suis heureux qu on ait pu
débattre sur le fond de la faire
puisqu'on voit qu'en fait le fond de la
faire il est vide on a des mensonges du
policier maxime demers et de principes
de tous ses collègues du début à la fin
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de boris johnston avec un
20 2 millions de britanniques qui ont
déjà reçu leurs premières doses du
vaccin anti qu'ovide le premier ministre
se targuer d'avoir mis en oeuvre une
stratégie gagnante pour sortir de la
crise et puis elle nous évoquerons la
réunion virtuelle ce vendredi entre eux
joe biden et délié légende australiens
indiens et japonais dans le cadre du
dialogue quadri latéral pour la sécurité
avec pour objectif notamment de
contrebalancer la puissance chinoise
[Musique]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime
on parle de jay liste on parle de gens
qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême cerexhe est un terreau qui peut
favoriser l'extension du terrorisme ne
faut pas imaginer qu'il suffit
simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre pour
que l'islam c'est un big mac sont
embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils ont
été manipulés et d'autres qui agissent
de manière parfaitement consciente et
lucide je respecterai toujours
l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega nist
[Musique]
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
c'est
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même il
ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gars fall de l'apli qu'à la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom aide en ligne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu
les big for books les gaffes à
s'organiser pour annuler quelqu'un sur
internet ce quelqu'un c'était donald
trump quand il s'agit d'un bannissement
si général pour moi ce n'est pas aux
gaffes à et aux réseaux sociaux à
dolhain des entreprises privées de
prendre cette décision mais ça doit être
à la justice de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
freiner le réchauffement climatique tout
en stimulant la croissance voici a
grossièrement la finalité de ce que l'on
appelle communément la relance verte
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire comme
relance verte quand vous avez une
économie qui est entièrement mondialisée
c'est des mots c'est de la com j'ai non
seulement indispensable mais c'est une
condition survie à moyen et long terme
de l'espèce humaine
le premier grand sujet c'est de réduire
l'usagé du pétrole et du gaz comme aux
gestes quotidiens
oui il faudrait faire quelque chose mais
on ne s'en donne absolument pas les
moyens et on n'a pas du tout envie même
bill gates de dix ans son dernier
bouquin aucune travail terme est
possible si on relit pas notre
consommation d'énergie
monsieur le maire nous explique qu'on va
rembourser toutes leurs bêtises avec une
croissance exceptionnellement forte je
voudrais qu'on m'explique comment on va
arriver à baisser la consommation
d'énergie et faire 6% de croissance de
l'autre côté ça va être compliqué
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï pg les jeunes
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes le désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa papa pata
pata
vous avez envie de faire ça valait il
faut que leur qu'istres groove la
musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des vides à mon sens bête
il faut sortir les notes de leurs
univers carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez le
royaume uni prend sa revanche sur le
commune de 19 alors qu'il ya un an la
stratégie sanitaire du premier ministre
britannique dans les johnson était
pointée du doigt par bon nombre de pays
aujourd'hui la campagne de vaccination
massive permet d'enregistrer un adulte
vacciner sur trois une un retournement
de situation pour l'un des pays les plus
endeuillé d'europe cyrielle bruit une
stratégie qui peinait à convaincre il y
a encore quelques mois
et pourtant aujourd'hui plus de 11
millions de britanniques ont reçu leurs
deux doses de vaccin contre le coc vie
de 19 à titre de comparaison en france
seuls deux millions de personnes sont
vaccinées à ce jour un retournement de
situation surprenant puisqu'il ya un an
le royaume uni était pointée du doigt
pour sa tendance à minimiser les risques
du virus
le premier ministre boris johnson avait
même annoncé compter sur l'immunité
collective
d'après le conseil scientifique
britannique il fallait attendre que 60 %
de la population soit infecté par le
virus
nous nous basons sur la science et nous
ferons ce qu'il faut au bon moment nous
ne fermons pas je le répète nous ne
fermons pas les écoles maintenant à
contre courant le royaume uni ne
souhaite alors pas imposer de mesures
sanitaires strictes à sa population
pour le gouvernement et le conseil
scientifique il était trop tôt et des
restrictions aurait été
contre-productive il semble futile de
dire rester chez vous si vous avez des
symptômes mineurs attendait de le faire
quelques jours plus tard sous la
pression de l'épidémie qui progresse
boris johnson annonce la fermeture des
écoles
il faudra attendre le 24 mars 2020 pour
qu un confinement se met en place au
royaume uni pour une durée de trois
semaines durant cette pandémie le
royaume uni affiche un bilan humain
particulièrement lourd ce qui le place
parmi les pays les plus endeuillé
d'europe
alors comment expliquer ce retournement
de situation outre-manche
contre toute attente il pourrait s'agir
du prg excite si vous vouliez une seule
démonstration de l'importance du bric
cible vous l'avez si nous étions encore
dans lieu certaines personnes seraient
mortes alors qu'elles ne le sont pas il
n'y a pas de quoi se vanter c'est tout
simplement vrai avec son plan de
vaccination massif londres semble avoir
gagné une première bataille dans l'après
breakes site
le royaume uni s'est assuré une longueur
d'avancé sur la campagne vaccinale en
investissant dès cet été directement
auprès des laboratoires pfizer
astrazeneca
éval neva en comparaison l'union
européenne a attendu le mois de novembre
un programme qui semble aujourd'hui
avoir porté ses fruits et autres manches
fort de sa stratégie vaccinale boris
johnson a annoncé la réouverture des
bars et restaurants d'ici avril
l'objectif du gouvernement britannique
reste inchangée assuré une première dose
de vaccin à chaque adulte avant la fin
du mois de juillet boris johnson qui
dément tout blocage des exportations de
vaccins contre le coc vie 19 le premier
ministre britannique s'est exprimé au
parlement aujourd'hui concernant les
accusations l'union européenne en ce
sens une affaire qui risque de rajouter
de l'huile sur le feu sur les relations
poste près xi déjà particulièrement
tendu et pour en parler de cette
situation au royaume uni nous sommes en
direct depuis londres avec martin mc
coulis analyse politique c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir martin mc colis merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france dans
le disait un elle très critiqué au début
pour sa gestion du covin boris johnson
tire finalement son épingle du jeu avec
sa stratégie de vaccination de masse
c'est vraiment la remonte à da silva aux
dires de boris johnson c'est une grande
victoire pour boris johnson car au cours
de l'année passée il a commis beaucoup
d'erreurs mais il les a corrigés
il se retrouve nathan dans une posture
très avantageuse avec tous les deux le
transsexuel millions de personnes
vaccinées
les écoles ouverts wenzhou ont été tuées
le 29 mars les gens pourront recommencer
à se rencontrer
donc on revient à la normale et après
lui
d'ici au 21 juin la ville devrait
revenir complètement normal tout le
monde doit a continué cependant à porter
des masques et doit prendre soin de ne
pas se mêler à de grands rassemblements
car les scientifiques nous sommes
avertis il pourrait y avoir de nouvelles
flambées si l'on ne respecte pas ces
règles
porter un masque et éviter les grands
rassemblements
alors surtout on le disait le royaume
uni qui fait pâlir d'envié les européens
22 millions de britanniques vacciner une
dose contre 4 millions en france est
définitivement la revanche de l'europe
un message clair à l'europe en tout cas
sur le plan sanitaire était très en
colère ce n'est pas passé pour la cause
des accusations portées par exemple
manuel macro winhouse cher monsieur
charles michel le yukon présidente de la
commission européenne le président du
conseil européen parle de nationalisme
vaccinale disant qu'elle est le royaume
uni a interrompu l'exportation des
vaccins vers l'europe
le secrétaire était très en colère et a
convoqué un diplomate de l'union
européenne lui a demandé de retirer je
vous cette déclaration et jamy chef
devra sans doute bientôt rejeté cette
déclaration la retirer les relations
entre le royaume uni et les européennes
sont assez tendus du point de vue brooks
et loire il faut trouver quelqu'un à
blâmer
ils ont été très incompétents dans la
production vaccinale
ils n'ont pas réussi à faire vacciner la
population
il cherche donc autour d'eux d'autres
pays à blâmer
le royaume uni qui a beaucoup de succès
avec ses deux vaccins astrazeneca
c'est regrettable si l'on regarde le
mignon européennes neuf jours et là j'ai
échoué à le produire un mouvement une
politique à l'échelle européenne la
hongrie importe le vaccin spécule fait
de la resituer google l'italie va
bientôt bas le produire des vaccins
et on vient d'apprendre que la
république tchèque la bulgarie et la
pologne connaissent des nombre
grandissant de contamination à l'aco
vide lui donc il y à une crise en europe
et du point de vue britannique
cette crise en tout cas au royaume uni
arrive à sa fin clairement peut-on dire
aujourd'hui la lumière voilà deux de ces
commentaires que c'est vraiment la
revente de l'état nation que la
souveraineté le souverainisme de chaque
pays jouent en la faveur dans cette
pandémie qu'il vaut mieux être en europe
aujourd'hui pour mieux gérer la pandémie
clairement la raison du succès du
royaume uni les rôles principaux
c'est michael aura lui a pu prendre ses
propres décisions et changer de cap au
cours de l'année passée le gouvernement
de brescia ne sonne pas commis de
nombreuses erreurs mais il a rectifié
corriger ses erreurs et et graduellement
pas venu au succès
effectivement le royaume uni était resté
au sein de l'union européenne cela
arrêté impossible le gouvernement a pu
agir très rapidement et l'union
européenne est très lente dans sa
permission la commission européenne a
démontré son incompétence
s'agissant de crise nationale s'agissant
de crise à l'échelle de l'union
européenne
cela a forcé des pays tels que la
hongrie ou l'italie importé des vaccins
de cussy ce qui ne devrait pas être le
cas
l'union européenne devrait être capable
de fournir des vaccins à l'ensemble de
l'union européenne mais elle a été aussi
incompétente qu'elle a échoué donc c'est
vraiment un échec retentissant de
l'apéro grassi et robben van der leyen
et charles michel sont coupables pour
cela il faut les blâmer le royaume uni a
de la chance de ne plus être membre de
l'union européenne en tout cas c'est ce
qu'il dit je le fais car ils ont pu
prendre des décisions rapidement changer
le cap rapidement sans être redevables
de bruxelles car consulter bruxelles
nécessite beaucoup de temps avant de
recevoir une décision elle avait aussi
outre les considérations de santé
publique qui sont évidemment les plus
importantes ça veut aussi dire que le
royaume uni va s'en sortir mieux d'un
point de vue économique
l'été et aura une longueur d'avancé par
rapport aux autres pays européens en
tout cas qui sont restés dans l'union
européenne y est et griche à dubaï la
grèce et l'espagne lui tous espèrent
accueillir des touristes britanniques
bénéficiant d'un passeport vaccinale qui
prouve qu'ils ont été qu'ils ont reçu
les deux doses du vaccin
j'ai été vacciné une fois je recevrai ma
deuxième dose en mai et on espère un
rappel en automne pour lutter contre les
variants venant du brésil et d'ailleurs
je peux la grèce et l'espagne ont
désespérément besoin de ces touristes de
bréteil au cas cela pourrait être
possible mais le royaume britannique
demande à ses citoyens d'attendre un peu
avant de faire leurs réservations
j'avais réservé des vacances ils violent
cornouaille en juillet
j'espère que moi même ma partenaire pour
nous y rendre
mais je n'ai pas réservé mes vacances en
espagne ou en grèce car le niveau
d'incertitude est trop élevé cependant
il est certain que ces pays ont hâte de
recevoir les touristes britanniques car
sans eux leur économie les jambes pour
lui il est très instable
tu prends du oui j'aurais pu vous
laisser terminer votre phrase merci
martineau mec cool et analyste politique
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france la vaccination en bosnie
herzégovine débute ce mercredi pour le
corps médical grâce à l'aide de la
serbie la situation dans le pays se
dégrade de jour en jour alors que les
autorités avaient commandé des doses de
vaccin anti covit par le biais du
dispositif kovacs et dense qui n'ont
toujours pas été livré les détails des
mayas soubelet une vaccination à
retardement qui a pu démarrer grâce à la
serbie ce mercredi la bosnie herzégovine
à administrer ses premières doses de
vaccin au personnel soignant et
technique et d'un hôpital de sarajevo
alors même que le pays connaît une
flambée épidémique
c'est un don de 10 mille doses du vaccin
astrazeneca réalisé par belgrade qui a
permis les premières injections
l'urgence se fait de plus en plus sentir
si nous repoussons la vaccination à
l'année prochaine cela n'aura aucun
effet nous devons nous procurer une
quantité importante de vaccins dès que
possible
vacciner rapidement et grâce à des
mesures restrictives strictes nous
pouvons ralentir l'épidémie
nous ne pouvons pas empêcher la
propagation de l'infection maintenant
car nous avons quatre semaines de retard
dans le cadre du programme international
kovacs initiée par l' oms
la bosnie avait commandé plus d'un
million deux cent mille doses de vaccin
mais les premières livraisons n'ont
toujours pas été effectuée la ministre
des affaires étrangères fait part du
mécontentement de la population
la bosnie herzégovine accrue aux
mécanismes kovacs à payer pour la
vaccination
mais la première livraison ne nous est
toujours pas parvenus et nos citoyens
sont à juste titre mais content pour 3
millions huit cent mille habitants
la bosnie enregis plus de 5000 décès duo
kobe 19,1 des chiffres les plus élevés
proportionnellement à sa population le
retard sur la vaccination n'aide en rien
le recul de l'épidémie
le bénéfice le plus important du vaccin
et que chacun d'entre nous qui est
vacciné ne mourra pas s'il vous plaît
c'est le bénéfice principal sans parler
de la prévention de la propagation du
feu
je n'ai pas d'anticorps et chaque jour
de travail pour moi un stress j'espère
que ce stress sera désormais réduits si
d'ici à quinze ou vingt jours mes
collègues sont affectés de la même façon
face à une recrudescence des cas les
autorités de sarajevo ont annoncé la
fermeture des bars restaurants et
magasins mon essentiel pour le week-end
prochain
la pression sur les hôpitaux étant
critique
les médecins ont également insisté pour
que la vaccination soit étendu à
l'ensemble de la population le plus
rapidement possible une nouvelle réunion
du quad ce vendredi les états unis le
japon l'inde et l'australie vont
s'entretenir virtuellement le but de
cette discussion parler de la pandémie
de kobe de 19 et du réchauffement
climatique
un dialogue bilatéral qui devrait
également tourner autour de la sécurité
dans l'espace indo pacifique notamment
face à la montée en puissance de la
chine pierre que sa vie verlan c'est une
première pour joe biden le président
américain participera vendredi à sa
première réunion du quad
après des entretiens avec le canada et
le mexique
washington l'a annoncé et souhaite
renouer avec ses alliés traditionnels
pour les états unis
la région représente un enjeu
stratégique important comme l'expliquent
la porte parole de la maison blanche
le fait que le président by day est
choisi d'en faire un de ses premiers
événements multilatéraux démontre
l'importance que nous donnons à une
coopération étroite avec nos alliés et
partenaires de la région indo pacifique
une série de sujets seront bien sûr
évoqué nous espérons parler de la menace
du coc vie 19 et de la coopération
économique et bien sûr la crise
climatique
au menu des discussions la crise
mondiale ducobu 19 et le réchauffement
climatique des dossiers régionaux et
mondiaux d'intérêt mutuel devrait aussi
être évoquée notamment celui de la
montée en puissance de la chine dans la
région
interrogé récemment sur le rôle anti
pékin du quad net price porte parole de
la diplomatie américaine a tenu à
préciser à que l'alliance n'étaient pas
forgé contre un seul adversaire pourtant
à l'occasion d'une réunion du quad en
octobre dernier mac pompéo avait appelé
à mettre fin à l'exploitation la
corruption et la coercition de pékin
dans la région
ce nouveau sommet de l'organisation
pourrait donc être vue d'un mauvais oeil
par la chine les relations entre pékin
et washington reste tendue même si les
deux parties vont se retrouver le 18
mars prochain en alaska et pour en
parler nous sommes avec l'eau blanche
maison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir maison la
relation n'est pas en parler entre eux
donc
un chef d'état en des quatre membres du
quad états unis australie japon et un
cela peut être considéré comme une
menace pour la chine
écoutez pas vraiment à ce stade
naturellement la chine protestera dira
que les états unis sont en train
d'essayer de former un nouveau nouvelle
alliance militaire du type de l'otan en
extrême orient comme ils l'ont dit
d'ailleurs en novembre dernier lorsque
les quatre mêmes pays ont mené des
manoeuvres aéronavales dans les eaux
dans les eaux du pacifique
et effectivement il faut comprendre que
la chine a depuis toujours un sentiment
d'enfermement à tort ou à raison parce
que elle est séparée du pacifique par le
japon par l'archipel japonais
il ya d'ailleurs et c'est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles elle revendique
l'ilsi coucou qui est actuellement sous
la gestion du japon et puis de la même
manière dans la mer de chine du sud elle
revendique que les archipels des
paracels et des spratleys qui sont
contestés par qui a par le vietnam et
par d'autres d'autres pays de la région
et puis surtout au milieu de cette zone
se trouve la grande île de taiwan qui
fait partie de la chine puisque
d'ailleurs tous les pays qui ont les
relations diplomatiques avec pékin
considère grave considérer qu'il ya une
seule chine et que taiwan en fait partie
les chinois regardent avec beaucoup
d'attention ce qui se passe à taïwan
et s'il part d' aventure fidh aventure
un gouvernement taïwanais déclaré
unilatéralement l'indépendance avec ou
sans l'appui des états unis eh bien ça
provoquerait certainement une
intervention militaire chinois mais cela
dit la chine n'est pas restée inactive
elle a joué délibérément la carte
économique
alors d'abord il faut il faut répéter
que la chine le premier partenaire
économique des trois pays asiatiques
dont nous parlons le japon l'inde et et
l'australie et puis deuxième élément en
novembre la chine a remporté un succès
diplomatique en enrôlant de ces pays le
japon et l'australie dans la signature
d'un vaste traité de libre-échange qui
couvrent l'essentiel de l'asie pas
l'inde parce que l'inde qui ait
participé à la négociation a décidé un
an auparavant
de sortir de cette négociation et par
conséquent de ne pas signer le traité
parce qu'elle craignait d'être submergé
par les biens de consommation chinois à
bas coûts et puis peut être aussi
qu'elle ne voulait pas participer à cet
ensemble
devinez par la chine donc effectivement
on voit là le rôle des grandes
puissances dans cette région est une
manifestation de la rivalité systémique
entre les etats-unis et la chine alors
que blanche raison quelles sont les
perspectives d'avenir de ce quad
cointreau ont chois alors à ce stade on
c'est difficile c'est difficile à dire
parce que ça n'est pas une alliance
militaire et on a bien vu
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure que les
ministres les quatre ministres qui se
sont réunis quatre mises affaires
étrangères et il ya la semaine dernière
ont discuté d'un tas de sujets
d'actualité bien sûr le coc vide
bien sûr la situation économique nous
aussi la sécurité dans la région
en élargissant les sujets en sortant de
la sécurité ce groupement se donne une
relative légitimité légitimité régional
puisqu'il ne se présente pas comme ayant
des finalités purement sécuritaire ou
aux militaires mais si la rencontre peut
enfin la discussion peut via internet
est un succès après demain le problème
est qu'il y aura d'autres candidats
parce que pourquoi est-ce que
l'australie ferait partie du coin n'est
pas la nouvelle zélande
pourquoi est-ce que le japon ferait
partie du quad et pas la corée du sud
sans parler d'autres pays qui semble
aussi être intéressant
c'est comme le vietnam ou d'autres pays
d'asie du sud est
et là les etats unis auront sans doute
un choix à faire soit à donner à cette à
cet embryon de l'organisation une
direction plutôt dirigé contre la chine
quel que soit le régime politique des
pays qui en font partie
ou bien ces temps en temps en tout cas
la tendance initiale de monsieur clinton
secrétaire d'état américain est sans
doute de joe biden données plutôt
l'aspect d'une d'une alliance des
démocraties contre les autocraties dont
contre la chine et aussi contre le
régime militaire de birmanie d'ailleurs
les ministres des affaires étrangères et
sont réunis la semaine dernière
l'église affaires étrangères du quad ont
pris position pour le retour à la
démocratie en birmanie
donc l'avenir est assez incertain
actuellement on est un peu à la croisée
des chemins et on verra en fonction la
discussion qui aura lieu entre les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement vendredi
quel sera le le stade futur la question
c4est pince qui est poursuivre vraiment
les mêmes objectifs
non pas vraiment pour le japon c'est
évidemment un très bon exemple de la
stratégie adoptée si fiq et le
préconisent depuis plusieurs années et
dont le premier ministre précédent au
japon monsieur shinzo abe s'était fait
l'avocat pour l'australie c'est
simplement et bien la sécurité dans la
partie ouest du pacifique
elle ne s'intéresse pas à d'autres
éléments pour les états unis
c'est peut-être l'embryon en effet d'une
alliance des démocraties asiatiques
contre les régimes dictatoriaux ou
autoritaires ou c'est peut-être un
cordon sanitaire qui vise à contenir
la montée en puissance de la chine mais
pour l'un de c'était quelque chose de
complètement différent puisque l'un
d'eux ne souhaitent pas souscrire
d'alliance militaire
pour elle c'est une carte supplémentaire
dans un jeu diplomatique et qui dans le
fond est un jeu tous azimuts
c'est à dire que l'inde c'est fort avoir
des rapports les meilleures possibles
avec la plupart des pays du monde
elle a d'ailleurs conclu un très grand
nombre de partenariats stratégiques
il se trouve que le premier d'entre eux
a été conclu en 1998 avec la france que
d'autres ont suivi avec la russie en
2000 pour renouer avec les liens
traditionnels que l'inde avait avec
l'union soviétique et d'autres ensuite
en 2004 avec le royaume uni avec les
états unis
puis d'autres avec d'autres pays
par conséquent l'inde ne veux pas avoir
un ami trop exclusif qui seraient les
états unis mais elle veut avoir comme
ami aussi les états unis et en effet ça
rendra le jeu un petit peu difficile
pour monsieur byden dans la discussion
avec d'art et un body d'autant plus que
narendra modi avait eu une très bonne
entente avec donald trump puisqu'ils se
sont rencontrés à plusieurs reprises et
que dans le fond les états unis
s'étaient rapprochés sensiblement de
l'inde
à cette occasion donc l'inde a des
soucis en effet géostratégique
c'est une puissance nucléaire et joue la
dissuasion c'est une puissance aussi
militaire classique qui surveille ses
frontières mais en même temps elle veut
garder les mains libres et avoir les
meilleures relations possibles avec le
plus grand nombre possible de pays merci
toad blanche maison pour votre analyse
rester avec mon dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la crise sanitaire
confinement prolonger ce week end
les alpes maritimes est toujours à
l'ordre du jour en ile de france
et puis nous parlerons
la loi séparatisme les églises
chrétiennes sont inquiètes pour leur
liberté et le font savoir dans une
tribune
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte on soit vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
[Musique]
l'actualité hervé morin c'est évidemment
la crise sanitaire ce que je défends
c'est bien sûr la territorialisation
d'injection d'épidémie on voit bien qu
un système centralisé bureaucratique tel
que celui ci a produit toute une série
de dysfonctionnements palmes masques
dans un premier temps pas de test dans
un second temps puis désormais une
insuffisance de vaccins on a senti que
vous étiez nerveux et agacé à l'encontre
de la politique de l'exécutif
quant à au déploiement de la vaccination
et je constate c'est qu'on est le 36e
pays en matière de vaccination
bon ça prouve à quel point on a un
système efficace
en normandie on aura deux usines qui
bientôt produiront des vaccins qui pour
l'un va être bientôt autorisés sur le
marché compte tenu de la faiblesse de la
vaccination je vois pas comment dans
quatre à six semaines
on pourrait se retrouver libéré
[Musique]
avec les accords d'abraham le président
américain reconnaît la souveraineté du
maroc sur le sahara occidental
la france comme l'europe a été absente
de l'ensemble de cette négociation qui
impactent directement deux pays dans
lesquels nous avons des liens
privilégiés depuis fort longtemps la
république algérienne et le royaume
humain des algériens évidemment
mécontents considère la décision
américaine comme une ingérence dans un
problème interne
le maroc a toujours été considérée comme
une menace politique économique et
militaire
face à cette situation conflictuelle
entre les deux pays la france aurait
ainsi l'occasion de participer à la
construction d'un maghreb pacifiées
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que le légat fall ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et dans l'hymne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et
big for donc les gaffes à s'organiser
pour annuler quelqu'un sur internet sur
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux hanul à des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il lui
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
vrai bon soin à tous merci nous rejoint
pour cette deuxième émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mercredi 10 mars à confinement
prolonger ce week-end dans les
alpes-maritimes toujours pas à l'ordre
du jour en ile-de-france en revanche le
porte parole du gouvernement qui a tenu
son habituel point presse alors qu'un
mouvement d'occupation des théâtres
s'est accélérée aujourd'hui en france
pour réclamer la réouverture des lieux
cultuels culturel un côté vaccination
l'objectif de 10 me dans vacciner d'ici
les prochaines semaines est toujours
possible selon gabriela le projet doit
peut être le séparatisme
il n'est pas sans inquiéter les
responsables des églises chrétiennes
alors que le texte sera bientôt examinée
par les sénateurs les responsables
catholiques protestants et orthodoxes de
france expriment leur défiance et dans
inquiétudes pour leur liberté dans une
tribune publiée par le figaro en grèce à
des heurts ont éclaté hier soir en marge
d'une manifestation contre de récentes
dérives policières dix policiers ont été
blessés 16 personnes arrêtées dans une
banlieue réputé calme d'athènes alors
que le pays est confinée depuis le 7
novembre et souvenirs un couvre feu
nocturne
certains dénoncent le virage autoritaire
du gouvernement
[Musique]
comme les discours de lula depuis qu'il
a été rétabli dans ses droits politiques
l'ex président brésilien fustige les
décisions je cite imbécile de jaillir
vol sudaro dans la gestion de la
pandémie les décisions qu'il invite à ne
pas suivre alors que le pays compte plus
de 260 8000 morts ou là qui nous d'avoir
été victime du pire mensonge judiciaire
en 500 ans
[Musique]
la situation sanitaire en france
prolongation du confinement le week-end
dans les alpes maritimes une mesure
encore écarté en ile de france malgré
des hôpitaux au bord de la saturation
on fait le point avec grégoire douce et
ce n'est pas ce week end que les mares
alpin pourront à nouveau fouler la
promenade des anglais
si l'exécutif se félicite des premiers
effets du confinement dans le
département des alpes maritimes
il juge qu'il est encore trop tôt pour y
mettre fin malgré déjà deux week-ends
consécutifs sous cloche il a été décidé
et je sais que c'est une décision
difficile de prolonger le confinement le
week-end pour ce week end et qu'un point
sera fait la semaine prochaine pour
mesurer si la dynamique de diminution de
l'incidence et de l'épidémie dans ce
département se poursuit et dans ce cas
pouvoir envisager de lever la mesure une
visibilité réduite sur le calendrier
sanitaires pour le département
méditerranéen autres régions très
touchées par le virus actuellement les
hauts de france et l'île de france
dans le dunkerquois le confinement en
fin de semaine a été prolongé jusqu'à la
fin mars
paris et ses alentours devraient en
revanche encore échapper à cette mesure
la région francilienne qui s'apprête à
transférer des patients hospitalisés
dans les prochains jours même stratégie
d'urgence dans le nord du pays ces
transferts concerneront des hôpitaux
belges frontaliers partenaire habituel
des hôpitaux français dans le cadre
d'accords transfrontalier il pourrait
être organisée dès mercredi ou dans les
prochains jours selon les capacités
d'accueil disponibles l'éligibilité de
patients et l'accord des familles pour
enrayer l'épidémie le gouvernement
compte plus que jamais sur la campagne
de vaccination
à l'heure actuelle plus de 4 millions de
français ont reçu au moins une dose du
remède objectif d'ici la mi-avril
atteindre les 10 millions de primo
vacciner illustration d'une campagne
parfois ubuesques alors que de nombreux
français pensent à se faire vacciner
boyer présidente de la communauté de
communes du pays de limours a refusé 150
doses de vaccin le week-end dernier
l'élu de l'essonne puis cette décision
parce que le personnel de vaccination
étaient au repos sur les réseaux sociaux
plusieurs maires du secteur compte est
aussi une décision qu'il juge
unilatérale le maire de janvry a écrit
hier pour préfet par exemple pour
dénoncer le manque de communication
entre les communautés de communes et les
maires du secteur et christian schoettel
maire centriste de janvier dans
l'essonne et autres mythes et ce soir
bonsoir christian chatel merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
illustration de ce que la campagne de
vaccination a peut-être de plus ubuesque
cette décision que vous jugez
unilatérale et inacceptable près presque
criminel quoi je veux dire que 250
vaccin alors que on est dans une période
d'anxiété ou nous et nos personnes les
plus affaiblis n'arrivent pas à trouver
de rendez vous c'est consternant de
refuser 150 vaccin alors que un élu
local comme moi et eu un petit maire
vous savez un tout petit tout petit père
les gens c'est pas des chiffres cdc des
vrais gens avec des vrais noms et que se
dire que celui-là ne sera pas vaccinés
ce week-end parce que on a on a refusé
de prendre les vaccins sous prétexte que
ya pas de secrétariat disponible c'est
juste consternant mais mais ça ressemble
un peu à la pétaudière général du
traitement de la vaccination je dois
vous christian chassaing pour bien qu'on
comprenne quand même parce que ça paraît
effectivement incroyable qu'on se dise
on l'a 150 doses de vaccins qu'on
n'utilise pas parce que le personnel est
au repos la première question que sont
devenus ces doses et 2
m on n'a pas essayé de trouver justement
peut-être du personnel disponible pour
traiter ces doses alors bien
heureusement et doses ont été réparties
on parle par le préfet ailleurs dans le
département
et elles vont servir à quelqu'un alors
tant mieux
en réalité il ya une décision
unilatérale de de la présidente de la
communauté de communes qui est dit bono
mon personnel est au repos donnez les à
quelqu'un d'autre
ce qui est consternant un je vous le dis
moi je suis ulcérée parce qu' on est
dans un cas de donna six ans à personne
en danger quoi aujourd'hui clairement
vous attendait une réponse du préfet
quelle serait cette réponse
satisfaisante pour vous écouter pour moi
c'est pas moi qui devrais dire ça en
tant qu'élu mais je pense que c'est très
grave de confier des problèmes
sanitaires à des élus parce que il faut
vraiment un vrai professionnalisme
il faut mettre en oeuvre on a un hôpital
de proximité serait dû être lui qui
devrait gérer des vaccinations plutôt
que année lui qui est peut-être pas
complètement pris la mesure de ses
fonctions donc c'est vrai que on
aimerait du professionnalisme
on aimerait de la cohérence et on
aimerait que que l'état ne fasse pas un
peu du stop and go / sur ce qui nous
arrive c'est un chatel
c'est vrai que c'est pas évident parce
qu'on a entendu beaucoup d'élus en
france se plaindre que l'éthane le
distribuer pas assez les responsabilités
on région
victoire et c'est vrai qu'on voit aussi
les quoique ça peut provoquer quand vous
dites les deux nous mêmes ce sont les
élus qui gèrent finalement alors qui
doit gérer ces vaccinations que ça
fonctionne correctement écouter on a un
système de santé on a des médecins on a
du pharmacien on a des hôpitaux
c'est l'ours et ils savent faire c'est
leur profession moi quand je vois l'état
qui me dit il faut vous embauche y est
les secrétaires qui prennent des rendez
vous etc etc on réinvente l'eau chaude
et ça me paraît extrêmement dangereux ne
serait ce que pour des raisons de
clientélisme tout d'un coup je fais
vacciner mes copains et pas les autres
enfin on imagine toutes les dérives
possibles
alors que on a assez encore une fois les
pharmaciens les médecins les hôpitaux
sont à disposition c'est leur job et je
pense que il ya rien de pire qu'un élu
qui se déclare compétent excusez-moi de
cette curiosité mais je le pense très
fort
les médecins et les pharmaciens sont
bien dotés chez vous dans votre commune
aux alentours ont là aussi vous remarqué
des couacs
écoutez moi ce que je remarque c'est que
même les personnes de plus de 75 ans dit
fragile n'arrivent pas à trouver de
rendez vous chez nous et donc si vous
regardez sur les sites d'octo libé
autres comment prendre un rendez vous et
que vous ne l'avez pas et donc ça n'est
pas possible j'ai en plus année c'est
encore moins possible de refuser 150
doses
imaginez que sur notre secteur s'il dans
quinze jours trois semaines et il y
avait une personne fragile qu'idc des
ducs au vide parce qu'elle a pas eu de
rendez vous on serait on serait des
criminels effectivement merci en tout
cas pour ce témoignage afin de châtel
qui nous montrent effectivement certains
côté us de cette campagne de vaccination
dans notre pays merci à vous d'avoir été
en direct assure rt france
et dans le sillage de la crise sanitaire
et de ces restrictions au mouvement
d'occupation des théâtres commence à
prendre de l'ampleur en france initié il
ya une semaine par l'odéon à paris
deux autres établissements participent
depuis mardi à cette action symbolique
pour réclamer la réouverture des lieux
culturels et une prolongation de l'année
blanche pour les intermittents
pour plus de précisions nous
retrouverons tout de suite mona hameau
dès lors en direct du théâtre de l'odéon
bonsoir à vous êtes donc sur place que
les militants occupent encore les lieux
il exactement ils occupent les lieux
depuis le jeudi 4 mars on est au coeur
du théâtre de l'odéon et souvenez-vous
c'est un lieu hautement symbolique
puisqu'en mai 68 il avait également été
occupé par des militants et puis c'était
devenu un lieu de meetings politiques
aujourd'hui ils sont un peu plus d'une
quarantaine occupé clairement les lieux
je suis avec elsa et rebecca elsa qui
est régisseuse bonsoir à vous merci
d'être avec nous et rebecca qui est
comédienne et elles sont ici là depuis
plusieurs jours certaines depuis un peu
plus longtemps
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous a
expliqué nous ainsi qu'est ce qui se
passe ici clairement c'est le centre
d'auch pas puisqu'on voit l'eau de la
nourriture on voit des instruments de
musique
du coup on est mobilisé ici à l'odéon
avant tout pour pouvoir donner la parole
à tous ceux qui sont muselés tous ceux
qui sont en souffrance depuis un an
via les agoras qu'on organise tous les
jours donc tout ça nécessite
effectivement une organisation assez
conséquente du point de vue de toutes
les questions d'hygiène d'alimentation
etc
ça s'est organisé en commission qui a
les commissions ravitaillement
communication voilà il ya énormément une
commission qui nous permettent
d'organiser l'ensemble de la
mobilisation est donc on le voit un
petit peu pour que les spectateurs
soient absorbées soit témoin de ce qui
se passe donc il ya des vivres
il ya de la nourriture il ya également
des vêtements ici et ce qui est un
sentiment aussi de solidarité qui s'est
créée bien sûr en fait depuis le début
de la mobilisation énormément de gens à
l'extérieur nous proposent leur soutien
nous demandent comment est ce qu'il peut
faire pour nous aider
et du coup on essaie de s'organiser pour
qu'on est
le maximum d'eux
de confort pour pouvoir continuer à
défendre nous non
revendications avec le plus grand test
simplement la visite de roselyne
bachelot le samedi 6 mars
elle a discuté avec les militants avec
les occupants légalement les syndicats
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que vous retenez de
cette visite finalement simplement
aucune réponse concrète
nous on veut des actes on veut des
décrets on
on veut à une mobilisation certaines du
gouvernement qui nous pousse à penser
que on va pouvoir avancer en fait tout
simplement on est là en fait pour
défendre tous les précaires de l'emploi
est ce qu on nous répond aujourd'hui
nous ne suffit pas tout simplement merci
beaucoup à elsa rebecca vous êtes
comédienne dont vous êtes directement
impactés par tout ce qui se passe en ce
moment
quelles sont les revendications on les
connaît mais on en vit surtout dans de
les entendre de la part d'une comédienne
car vous représentez aussi tous ces
intermittents du spectacle qui sont ici
à présent et qui occupent les lieux
depuis plusieurs jours oui en effet
alors est bon il ya une revendication
qui concerne plus particulièrement les
organisations qui ont appelé à la
mobilisation le 4 mars dernier qui est
pour l'instant sur le point d'aboutir
enfin on l'espère du moins
et qui permettrait de parler des
conditions de reprise éventuelle quand
tu es quand elle aura lieu mais la
revendication principale ici elle
concerne les droits sociaux la toute
première revendication en tête de liste
c'est l'abrogration l'abrogation de la
réforme d'assurance chômage qui qui est
repoussé par tous les syndicats mais que
le gouvernement souhaite mettre
néanmoins en place au 1er juillet alors
on va dire nous les intermittents du
spectacle on a eu une année blanche
on en demande la prolongation parce que
là on sait très bien que on pourra pas
renouveler nos droits au chômage et
reprendre correctement si elle n'est pas
prolongé mais par dessus tout on demande
qu'il y ait une équité entre tous les
travailleurs et que tous les autres tous
les autres intermittents de l'emploi qui
n'ont pas plu non plus travailler les
gens de l'événementiel de la
restauration du tourisme qui subissent
aussi même pas ralentissement ou un
arrêt total de leur secteur puisque le
public ne peut pas être présent non plus
mais également tous ceux qui sont
peut-être impacté moins directement
comme les pigistes des gens vacataires
de la recherche ou de houe de
l'enseignement en réalité il ya plus pas
mal de secteurs qui embauchent en
contrat court et on trouve choquant que
donc on ne donne pas des mêmes droits à
tous ces gens nous réclamons nos droits
et nous réclamons aussi donc une année
blanche pour eux enfin voilà est donc
une annulation de cette réforme parce
que elle est catastrophique elle va
abaisser les droits des chômeurs pile au
moment où on est en pleine crise
sanitaire
la mesure du calcul a été annulée par le
conseil d'état mais le gouvernement
tient quand même à continuer à faire des
économies sur le dos des chômeurs c'est
voilà c'est proprement impossible donc
il ya diverses revendications les
revendications liées au secteur
je vous les ai dites là au début mais en
réalité on est ici comme disait état
pour à des fins droite tous les
précaires et on appelle à occuper
partout tous les lieux de culture parce
que nous on est une caisse de résonance
le monde du spectacle
on le sait mais également ceux qui
veulent occuper d'autres lieux ça les
gars vous êtes comédienne aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui vous manque parce que
votre métier c'est aussi un métier de
contact mais qu'est ce qui vous manque
le plus au 6 mai je vous dirai
évidemment le public nous manque
enfin on se dire que travailler en
sachant pas quand on retrouve le public
c'est compliqué mais ce qui me manque
c'est aussi mes collègues je vais vous
parler très franchement je suis
comédienne je travaille donc
parfois au cinéma parfois au théâtre
mais je travaille aussi dans
l'événementiel avec les gens dont je
viens vous parler je vais les retrouver
quand quand les lieux rouvriront où les
événements se reforme et je ne vois pas
les retrouver les regarder dans les yeux
et me dire qu'on n'a pas eu les mêmes
droits
c'est pour moi totalement inadmissible
ce qui me manque c'est de voir s'élancer
le lien social comme tout le monde mais
c'est de voir que les gens sont en perte
de lien social mais aussi qu'ils
s'appauvrissent sacré des dépressions
sacré des suicides un sacré s'est passé
pas nui
merci beaucoup ont rêvé cas pour ce
témoignage merci à vous vous l'avez
entendu des revendications qui une
parole qui a porté en tout cas pour
beaucoup d'intermittents mais pas
seulement tout ce qui se plaignent de
des acquis sociaux qui est qu'ils n'ont
pas donc vous l'avez vu on est au coeur
de ce théâtre de l'odéon un lieu
hautement symbolique et vous le voyez
sur les images de baptiste gosselin des
vivres sont mis ici pour occuper le plus
longtemps possible ce théâtre pour
l'instant aucune décision n'a été émise
il ya des âges assemblée générale tous
les soirs et tous les jours à 14 heures
à l'appel de la sainte du syndicat la
cgt
ils se rassemblent juste devant l'hôtel
le le théâtre merci on avait compris
merci madame ou dès lors en direct du
théâtre de l'odéon
le projet de loi contre le séparatisme
poursuit son parcours législatif alors
que le texte sera examiné par les
sénateurs à partir du 30 mars les
responsables catholiques protestent et
entonox de france d'ailleurs exprimé
leur inquiétude est aussi devant ce
projet les doigts dans une tribune
publiée par le figaro sont ces conforter
des principes républicains c'est un
texte qui est selon je suis triste de
porter atteinte aux libertés
fondamentales que sur les libertés de
culte d'associations d'anciens du mans
et même à la liberté d'opinion malmené
déjà par une police de la pensée qui
s'installe de plus en plus dans
espace commun alors les libertés des
églises chrétiennes sont elles en danger
avec le projet de loi séparatisme c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage avec nos
invités et pour en parler nous sommes
avec jean benoit harel fondateur de
l'association pour la messe bonsoir
venons à rennes merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france michel dubost
évêque émérite du diocèse d'évry corbeil
essonnes orthodoxes protestants et
catholiques dont tous d'accord pour
exprimer leur défiance vis-à-vis de ce
projet de loi c'est un texte qui qui
rassemble dans la défiance que
craignez-vous - suarez précisément il ya
plusieurs choses à craindre mais je
pense que la première chose à remarquer
c'est c'est d'abord en fait tout
simplement cette tribune vous l'avez dit
qui a été signé par par les trois
représentants des églises chrétiennes
protestantes orthodoxes et catholiques
et c'est finalement dans ces deux
tribunes où on y apprend beaucoup de
choses c'est un petit peu le presque le
monde à l'envers on me dit on à la
défense de la loi de 1905 par les
représentants des cultes alors que bon
ça a été un petit peu compliqué il ya
son temps pour mettre en place cette loi
cette loi a été mise en place et
progressivement elle a été acceptée
voilà tout le monde
c'est faire cette loi on ajoutait
laïcité dite à la française et
aujourd'hui c'était mon seigneur eric de
moulins beaufort et c est le
représentant donc des protestants et des
orthodoxes qui doivent rappeler au
gouvernement l'importance de cette
laïcité alors que la loi est censée je
suis conforté les principes républicains
donc voilà je pense que le premier pas
le principal problème c'est qu'on fait
de la religion une menace a priori dans
l'espace public
or en fait moi je pense que ce n'est pas
la religion qui est une menace à l'ordre
public mais c'est le fanatisme et si on
cible la religion je pense qu'on
encourage d'une certaine manière le
fanatisme
quand la république vient dire à un
catholique à un chrétien un musulman à
un juif ta religion est un problème pour
moi elle a l'air problème pour la
république avec un poème pour les
principes républicains et a finalement
on instaure cette méfiance entre la
république et l'évolution est donc on
pousse ces croyants dans les bras du
fanatisme alors que c'est le principe
tout c'est exactement ce qu'on voulait
éviter
alors michel dubost merci aux siens
d'être avec nous avant de vous faire
réagir je vous propose d'écouter
françois clavero lee président la
fédération protestante de france
écoutez ce qu'il en dit de cette loi
pourquoi viser les associations
cultuelles qui sont majoritairement
protestante et juive
c'est à dire des associations dont les
membres respectent les principes de la
république depuis 115 ans
l'accumulation de mesures de contrôle et
de surveillance et à force de soupçon
donne l'impression d'être issu d'un
projet pour freiner cette vie cultuelle
et c'est en ce sens que nous disons il y
un risque il y à une menace qui pèse sur
la liberté d'exercice du culte par
l'accumulation de ces mesures
on va essayer de lire entre les lignes
il ne faut pas être hypocrite que
voulait dire françois clavero lee
pourquoi viser aussi les juifs et les
protestants alors que tout le monde dans
le fond c'est que c'est
clairement radical qui est visé par ce
texte le premier ministre ne s'en est
d'ailleurs pas caché
de fait c'est une loi qui est fait pour
contre le séparatisme des islamiques et
n'est pas faite contre l'islam qui n'est
pas raid contre une jeune fille d'alice
contre le christianisme donc la nissan
nismo radical j'ai bien dit c'est très
important de le souligner
j'ai perdu monsieur michel debost
pardonnez moi on a aussi pour elle de
son jeu je vais me tourner vers un jean
benoit rennes en espérant que le som
reviennent chez notre évêque émérite du
diocèse d'évry corbeil essonne s'est
toujours pas le cas non manifestement
peut-être un petit anti tht et c'est son
nom c'est toujours pas le cas de jean
benoît râle c'est vrai voilà ça veut
dire un gros col aînés nés juifs les
catholiques les protestants serait d'une
certaine manière froid c'est alors que
ce texte vise de l'aveu même du premier
ministre
l'islamisme radical l'islam radical je
pense qu'il faut revenir aussi à
l'origine de ce projet et on voit qu'il
ya une évolution sémantique très
intéressante dans l'origine de ce projet
à la base donc c'était évidemment pour
lutter contre l'islam radical contre
l'islamisme ensuite il a fallu lutter
contre les séparatismes et aujourd'hui
on a une loi qui ne veut finalement plus
rien dire qu'il protège
dié sensibles protégés les principes
républicains peut absolument plus rien
dire et effectivement le fait de mettre
tout le monde dans le même panier de m
l'islamisme et le judaïsme de mettre
l'islam radical et les le christianisme
dans le même panier on a en a un
problème parce que il n'y a pas de il
n'y a pas de fanatisme chrétien n'a pas
de fat de fanatisme catholique c'est
quoi un fanatique catholique c'est
quelqu'un qui va dans le métro et qui
dit jésus vous n
donc je pense que il ya une différence
fondamentale entre les religions et
l'islamisme et le gouvernement a du mal
à assumer cette distinction sous la
terre de se faire taxer d'islamophobe
alors là on n'a malheureusement pas
toujours toujours pas récupéré michel
dubois ça c'est pour ça que je me
retourne pas avec lui
n'ayez crainte vous êtes seul dans cette
interview
mais ça va très bien on va écouter
justement philippe bas sur ce thème un
questeur du sénat ce sénateur et
conseiller départemental de la manche
sur cette loi sur le séparatisme vous
espérez faire sortir les salafistes des
mosquées mais alors où iront ils
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que la
combinaison de la liberté de réunion et
de la liberté d'expression leur
permettent de se tourner vers d'autres
lieux que les mosquées pour reprendre
leur propagande
et si tel devait être le cas nous
serions en quelque sorte mieux protéger
contre l'intrusion du politique dans les
lieux de culte que contre la diffusion
d'une idéologie subversive en dehors des
lieux de culte on risque d'en mettez
tous les cultes sans distinction qui ne
pose aucun problème à la république pour
un résultat qui serait absolument
dérisoires dans notre volonté de faire
reculer le séparatisme donc jean benoit
rlc bien ça le problème c'est que ce
texte il ratisse trop large il ne répond
à aucune dérive
c est finalement un test époque rites je
pense que c'est un texte hypocrite on
peut prendre un exemple très simple
l'exemple du contrôle du financement des
lieux de culte
le projet de loi aujourd'hui alourdi
füle et procédures du financement des
lieux de culte notamment sur sur les
financements qui viennent de l'extérieur
et il cible à moka c'est évidemment le
financement par les pays étrangers
notamment l'arabie saoudite des mosquées
en france puisque ensuite l on a une
influence à travers cette ce financement
est aujourd'hui on va alourdir les
procédures qui sont des traces et
l'autre pour tous les cultes on va créer
des garanties pour des associations
spécifiquement cultuelle quand d'autres
associations absolument pas toutes ces
garanties
voilà pour un objectif qui est caché on
cible
absolument tout le monde est
effectivement je pense qu'il ya une
certaine hypocrisie dans dans ce projet
de loi cette fois l'église ne saurait
peut délivrer des contraintes de l'état
c'est en quelque sorte un retour en
arrière selon vous eh bien c'est ce que
dit aussi la tribune c'est à dire que
c'est un peu un retour en arrière au
contrôle de type concordataire c'est à
dire le contrôle qui existait au 19e
siècle on avait un contrôle dans
l'établissement de litas sur sur la
religion notamment les catholiques et
est donc là on arrive on revient en tout
cas ce système où l'état s'immisce dans
la religion alors que la laïcité dite à
la française était justement l' inverse
c'est à dire que c'était chacun chez soi
la république s'occupe de la sphère
publique
en tout cas ce qui est sûr s'occupe de
l'état et la sphère religieuse s'occupe
de la sphère religieuse est en fait
aujourd'hui on mélange un peu tout ça et
on arrive à interdire des choses dans
l'espace public
l'idée de la laïcité voilà ça c'est
justement de séparer les deux
et aujourd'hui on mélange tout l'état
l'état veut
s'immiscer veut prendre le contrôle un
petit peu de l'art et de la religion
généralement pour un souci sécuritaire
mais aussi pour d'autres d'autres
raisons et je pense que le lien il ya un
problème la laïcité à la française elle
a marché pendant 105 ans alors il faut
peut-être l'adapter 1
là tout ce qui dans le projet de loi
aujourd'hui n'est pas mauvais il ya
notamment une lutte contre les mariages
forcés contre les discriminations voilà
donc on a quand même des avancées qui
sont nécessaires et qui sont adaptés à
notre temps aujourd'hui et le
gouvernement malheureusement bien
souvent trop loin dans ce contrôle est
alors qu'il faudrait juste une
adaptation de cette laïcité de l' issue
de la loi 1905
on a un bouleversement de cette loi
clairement qu est ce que vous craignez
concrètement qu'est ce qui peut arriver
justement pour les comptes juifs les
cultes chrétiens parce que si on va par
là on peut se dire bah ils vont vous
fichent la paix avec les contrôles
puisque cette loi vous dit l hypocrite
elle vise en réalité une escale radical
alors évidemment et vise héliciel vise
islam radical en fait tout le monde est
touché donc au final il ya quand même de
nombreuses répercussions je veux citer
par exemple le contrôle du financement
qui va alourdir les procédures il ya
aussi au delà de la simple liberté du
culte entre guillemets et aussi la
neutralité de l'enseignement catholique
qui est remise en question
l'enseignement en famille il ya beaucoup
de
deux restrictions sur sur les écoles
hors contrats qui sont qui sont en train
d'être débattue et donc on a en a
véritablement une restriction des
libertés
tout ça pour un souci sécuritaire alors
le souci sécuritaire montbarnier il
existe vraiment que ce soit au niveau de
la crise sanitaire au niveau 2 les
violences physiques a donc emmené comme
des attentats dont il ya un problème
sécuritaire mais il ne peut pas être
l'alpha et l'oméga de toute décision
politique
on sait qu'il ya une tension entre
liberté et sécurité et aujourd'hui le
gouvernement tend à donner plus de
sécurité et donc à restreindre à
restreindre les libertés et au premier
chef la liberté de culte
merci en tout cas jambonneau harel et on
s'excuse auprès de michel dubost évêque
émérite du diocèse d'évry corbeil
essonnes pour ce problème de sons qui
nous a empêchés malheureusement d'avoir
un débat avec vous et d'entendre sa voix
en tout cas merci à lui et surtout merci
à vous aux jambes aux noix harel d'avoir
été en direct avec nous on est bien en
tout cas compris ce qui vaut au
chiffonné si je peux me permettre dans
cette loi merci à vous restez avec nous
partirons en grèce où des affrontements
ont éclaté en marge d'une manifestation
qui a rassemblé 5000 personnes contre
les violences policières et puis
direction le brésil premier discours de
lui
depuis qu'elle était rétablie dans ses
droits politiques l'ex président
brésilien fustige les décisions je suis
un imbécile de ja rbl solar ou dans la
gestion de la pandémie
[Musique]
louis saillant est un mec ce commando
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi la barre est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser l'extension du
terrorisme ne faut pas imaginer qu'il
suffit simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre
pour que l'islam c'est un guillaume a
qui sont embrigadés ils ont été séduits
ils ont été manipulés et d'autres qui
agissent de manière parfaitement
consciente et lucide je respecterai
toujours mon l'adversaire même si je
méprise totalement son idéologie comme
c'est le cas pour sega liste
[Musique]
21h30 merci de rejoindre en direct sur
rt france la grèce sous le choc au
lendemain d'une nuit de violences à
athènes une manifestation contre les
dérives policières qui a dégénéré en
cause la vidéo d'un homme passé à tabac
qui a fait le tour des réseaux sociaux
donc on vise ouardi policiers blessés
dont un grièvement 16 interpellations
mettent ils rejoignent les flics hors de
nos quartiers
c'est ce qu'on pouvait lire sur les
banderoles des manifestants à athènes ce
mardi environ 5000 personnes ont défilé
dans la capitale grecque contre les
violences policières
des échauffourées ont éclaté dans la
soirée les forces de l'ordre ont fait
usage de gaz lacrymogènes
comme on peut le voir sur ces images
aériennes publiée par la police grecque
des cocktails molotov ont été lancés sur
le commissariat de nea smyrni c'est dans
cette banlieue pourtant réputé calme
qu'un jeune homme a été frappé dimanche
à coups de matraques par un policier
lors d'un contrôle des mesures de
confinement
face à cette escalade de violence le
premier ministre grec appel au calme
il est vrai c koi nage vih pouvait
remercier importe c'est un fait mais les
tristes images de violence que nous
avons tous vu ce soir à athènes doivent
être les dernières la vie d'un
concitoyen
le jeune policier qui était en danger
doit être un signal d'alarmé dans ces
moments là maîtrise de soi et le calme
doit prévaloir
je ne permettrai à personne de nous
diviser les forces de l'ordre et les
habitants de nea smyrni ont deux
versions différentes des faits qui se
sont déroulés dimanche les policiers
affirment d'avoir été pris à partie par
une trentaine de personnes lors de
contrôles du respect du couvre feu
du côté des habitants on assure que
l'homme frappé par le policier voulait
simplement discuter avec les agents
une enquête a été ouverte par le parquet
et par la police en internat et pour en
parler non seulement avec un dimitri et
4 solos ce professeur l'hiver
j'étais tentée ont des sciences sociales
et politiques bonsoir des crises
qu'elles sony ça merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france de
l'opposition par l'intermédiaire de
l'ancien ministre sery prince a dénoncé
une attaque en l'absence de provocations
policières contre les familles et les
jeunes enfants ce sont des décès
agissements précis qui ont mis le feu
aux poudres problèmes qu'on comprenne on
doit examiner et voir le problème
principal est le problème semble ainsi
parle c'est que le phénomène de la
violence policière et de l'impunité des
policiers en ré ce n'est pas un
phénomène un problème récent ce n'est
pas nouveau
au contraire on observe depuis des
années mais mais le phénomène est devenu
beaucoup plus grave
ces dernières années en effet nous
assistons à une violation systématique
systématique des lois par des policiers
et en particulier la violation du décret
présidentiel de 54 de l'année 2004 qui a
trait aux codes déontologiques de la
police à cela il faut ajouter
l'interdiction systématique au cours des
derniers mois des rassemblements et
manifestations
ce qui au contraire à la constitution
l'article 11 paragraphe 2 donc nous
vivons la pire situation depuis la chute
de la dictature en 1974
quant aux libertés démocratiques et en
plus il ne faut pas oublier que tous et
là je passe en parallèle avec une
insatisfaction grandissante des
travailleurs des chômeurs des jeunes par
rapport aux inégalités de plus en plus
importante dans notre société
et tout cela tout cela explique ce qu'on
a vu dans l'est les télévisions de
l'image
tout cela explique l'explosion de la
colère de la population du pays alors la
presse grecque de droite comme de gauche
en fait assez rare est unanimement sens
pour dénoncer cette augmentation de 2
lens et des bavures policières ces
dernières semaines c'est un constat qui
est qui est réel qui est palpable en
grèce il est certain que les citoyens le
peuple grec vous pour défendre la
démocratie et la liberté à suez par la
constitution
et ça c'était cette défense de la
démocratie des libertés va influencer le
cadre politique de notre pays
commissariat attaqué se situe dans un
quartier réputé au calme de la banlieue
d'athènes ça démontre quoi que le
malaise qui règne dans le pays se
généralise oui bien sûr de sûr et j'ai
dit il ya une colère de dans notre
peuple à cause exactement de la violence
policière de nos unités des postiers et
tout ça doit se terminer
oui pardonnez-moi la pandémie tco vide
est ce qu'un levier pour quelque chose
parce qu'on rend l'observent violence un
petit peu palpable on sous jacente même
nom dans beaucoup de pays en raison des
restrictions des confinement est ce
qu'on peut y voir un lien selon vous
bien sûr bien sûr parce que et les
mesures qui a pris le gouvernement
je tourne directement contre les
libertés c'est le basculement des
mesures pour affronter le problème de
covin il y a le gouvernement
pratiquement utilise la pandémie pour
voter des lois antidémocratiques
comme par exemple l'instauration de la
police universitaire pour vous il ya
clairement une arrière pensée de la part
du gouvernement parce qu'on rappelle
quand même effectivement quelle mesure
antico vide en grèce étaient parmi les
plus sévères
d'europe mais ce n'est pas que pour
lutter contre la pandémie savent pas
permet aussi de museler entre guillemets
pâte actuellement et fort une partie de
la population selon vous voyez je me
demande si le gouvernement grec veut
faire taire les protestations sociales
effectivement et à des protestations
sociales on rappelle que après dix ans
de crise économique cette crise du
combinat fait qu'empirer la situation du
pays le pays la grèce est au bord du
gouffre
la crise économique s'est énervé les
inégalités j'ai toujours rêvé aussi
merci dimitris 4 sonis d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france
professeur à l'université panthéon des
sciences sociales et politiques au
brésil premier discours de lula depuis
la réhabilitation ses droits politiques
l'ex président en a profité pour
vivement critiqué la gestion du cobp 19
de jaillir vol solar eux ils demandent
aux brésiliens de ne pas suivre je cite
les décisions imbéciles du gouvernement
l'homme de gauche n'a pas mâché ses mots
écoutez je sais que j'ai été victime du
plus grand mensonge juridique raconté en
500 ans d'histoire contades je sais que
ma femme maryse a est décédée à cause de
cette pression et l'accident vasculaire
cérébral s'est aggravée d'après ce que
vous avez fait frapper le faut nous
quittait grave s'il est un brésilien qui
a des raisons d'avoir beaucoup de
chagrin profond c'est moi mais je ne les
ai pas loupé
honnêtement je n'en ai pas parce que la
souffrance que traverse le peuple
brésilien la souffrance que vivent les
pauvres dans ce pays
sport est infiniment plus grande que
n'importe quels crimes qu'ils ont commis
autour de moi du poker et les brésiliens
sont partagés sur l'annulation des
condamnations de l'ex président lula
écouter ces quelques réactions dans les
rues de sao paulo
je suis pour la décision je suis pour le
parti des travailleurs
j'aime lula c'est le président que je
veux lire en 2022
je l'attendais la justice a commencé et
je crois que c'est le bon moment pour
que les gens réfléchissent aux
accusations et qui ont été faites pour
mieux voter en 2022
j'ai le sentiment que l'impunité s'est
accru au brésil nous sommes dans un
système où quelques-uns décide et où les
décisions ne sont pas prises dans
l'intérêt commun mais dans l'intérêt de
quelques-uns ce qui nuit au reste de la
population
le gouvernement est une chose sérieuse
et les choses doivent être prises au
sérieux
cette décision est absurde s'est fait
contrôler la loi les règles sociales et
contre l'intérêt commun
et pour en parler mon sens avec driss
galy spécialiste en relations
internationales bonsoir driss ben ali
merci d'être avec nous alors nous là qui
assure que pour le moment il n'a pas du
tout la tête à la candidature de 2022 on
peut le comprendre peut-être un peu
prématuré mais pourtant on a constaté
qu'il est bien tiré à boulet rouge sur
ball sonar ont clairement
bonsoir battre façon il ne peut faire
que ça parce qu'il est
il y pas aux affaires il est dans
l'opposition c'est très facile de se
joindre au choeur mondiale entre bôle
sonar ou de tisser la légende noire du
brésil qui est le sport favori de des
médias malheureusement à l'international
on pourrait revenir sur sur ce que vient
de dire lula qui étaient aux affaires au
brésil quand même pendant une douzaine
d'années lui son parti et qui ont laissé
au brésil un secteur hospitalier
sanitaires déplorables
kiko qu'il explique en partie le bilan
du coc vide au brésil il ya peu les
hôpitaux du brésil ne sont pas nés avec
vos leçons a row qui est au pouvoir
depuis moins de deux ans le régime de
monsieur lula et de madame dilma qui
était dans du même parti a bénéficié
d'une conjoncture économique
merveilleuse qui aurait pu permettre de
financer les hôpitaux brésilien est
malheureusement ce peuple brésilien de
quel auxquelles monsieur vous là aime se
référer a été privé de ça on a préféré
faire la coupe du monde nous rappeler la
coupe du monde et les jo de rio voilà
maintenant paie le prix il revenir sur
cette épidémie de covin effectivement
parce que lula a mis l'accent dessus
mais tout de même sur ses intentions
présidentielles parce que on a pensé à
ça forcément
hier il a quand même annoncé nous là
qu'il comptait parcourir à nouveau le
pays pour parler aux brésiliens je cite
je me sens encore assez jeune pour
lutter je veux que vous sachiez que je
n'abandonnerai jamais on rappelle qu'il
a quand même soixante quinze ans ça
ressemble quand même à une future
campagne ça ah oui c'est très possible
alors bon je voudrais vous dire quand
même
deux choses le contexte au brésil a
beaucoup changé
et dire que le populisme de lula a
aujourd'hui parce qu'il est populiste et
c'est pas un mot péjoratif il a devant
lui un concurrent de taille qui le
populisme de droite de gaulle son mari
et à mon humble avis a pas place au
brésil à 2 mobilisme le peuple brésilien
qui souffre elle alloue la raison le
peuple brésilien souffre depuis des
siècles il souffre encore plus sous
leuprolide le peuple brésilien à mon
humble avis à trouver dans vos leçons a
reconduit le peuvent faire les classes
populaires et les classes misérables a
trouvé à mon avis dans ball solaro le
populisme je le vois mal lula maintenant
venir et reconquérir ce peuple là lula
est très populaire où est populaire chez
les bourgeoisie urbaine un peu bobo à la
française parce que c'est l'idéal de che
guevara la démocratie tout ça et
deuxième chose on nous parlons beaucoup
de lula nous ne parlons pas de la
décision de la cour suprême brésilienne
qui l'a libéré de ses deux de ses
contraintes de ces condamnations
comme le fait du prince avant moyen-âge
c'est très très grave que vient de se
passer au brésil si on en a
effectivement parlé hier quand c'est
tombé mais apparemment vous avez envie
d'en parler très bien la cour suprême
brésilienne enfin ça veut dire aussi
puisqu'on parle de ça que nous là n'a
pas du tout été innocenté qui devra
peut-être certainement affronter un
autre tribunal
et ça sera peut-être une autre paire de
manches peut-être quand même condamné un
on n'en sait rien il ya une prescription
j'ai pas le chiffre en tête injuste et
combien d'années à partir desquels les
crimes font pardonner ya prescription
donc ils vont jouer ça certainement ce
que lula n'est pas n'est pas le
brésilien de base est parmi les
meilleurs avocats du brésil
et deuxième chose le brésil aujourd'hui
meurtrie
parce que vous avez quelqu'un qui a été
jugé par quinze juges au brésil qu'un
juge trois instances il a déposé sans
recours tous rejetés il a fait la prison
et vous avez un juge dans la cour
suprême qui comme ça se réveille le
matin il dit eh bien on n'aurait pas dû
juger lula à curitiba dans un tribunal
de province on aurait dû juger à
brasilia et donc vous avez la juge qu'
en droit
plusieurs années plus tard de dire que
tout le monde s'est trompé bien vous
imaginez le signal qui on voyait la
communauté internationale aux
investisseurs donc je ne sais pas si
lula sera à mon humble avis il ne sera
pas embêtés d'ici 2022 d'un point de vue
juridique
je pense pas qu'il soit encore devant
les tribunaux d'ici 2022 je pense qu'ils
donnent le chemin qui libre alors tout
cas il ya un sondage qui a été rendu
public aujourd'hui par l'institut real
time data ancien brasil il donne un bol
sonar ou en tête des intentions de vote
en évidence et a tout de suite l'enfant
c'est intéressant pour le premier tour
avec 43 % dont talonné par lula 39%
qu'est ce que ça dit ce sondage
justement selon vous il faudrait
regarder les la région effectivement
parce que il ya le vote ball son héros
était un roc du sud est et du centre
ouest ont dans les régions 10 ans rentre
guillemets même s'il faut faire
plusieurs lieux mais les plus riches du
brésil donc sao paulo rio et la région
de
le centre ouest d'affaires vers brasilia
et la gauche avait pris le nord d'ace
les gens les plus pauvres
j'ai l'impression que bolt son art au
s'implante fortement en horde est à
cause ou grâce aux trop vite parce qu'il
a distribué beaucoup d'argent de dette
sociale
il faudrait voir dans ses intentions de
vote où lula aurait encore ces 39%
de toute façon le brésil est largement
fracturé un c il a un côté nord
américain il ya les antilles les pro
bowl subaru et les gens ne se parlent
plus c'est dramatique je n'ai jamais vu
ça au brésil qui est un pays
consensuelle où la politique est moins
importante que le foot
et bien pourtant les gens ne se parlent
plus les familles sont divisées
c'est c'est comme ça c'est la
polarisation merci de risques d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur la france
pour parler de la situation brésil est
particulièrement de lula merci à vous
dans le reste dans le reste de
l'actualité tensions entre moscou et
twitter les autorités russes ont annoncé
vouloir ralentir le fonctionnement du
réseau social américain
dans le reste dans le pays elle accuse
de violer la loi en refusant de
supprimer des publications jugées
illégales par la russie notamment sur
les drogues le suicide la plateforme
fonctionne donc ont ralenti aujourd'hui
le point avec notre correspondant à
moscou antoine clairon les autorités
russes reprochent à twitter de ne pas
supprimer des contenus considérés comme
illégaux malgré de nombreuses demandes
plus en détail il s'agit de contenus
jugés pédo pornographique ou faisant
l'apologie des drogues ou du suicide
d'où cette décision prise par le
gendarme russe de l'internet et des
médias
nous avons prévenu l'entreprise twitter
à plusieurs reprises de la nécessité de
respecter les lois russes
à l'heure qu'il est plus de 3000
publications interdites n'ont pas été
supprimées qui ont été livrés il s'agit
d' images pornographiques de mineurs de
publication de méthodes de suicide
comprenant notamment des appels aux
mineurs à se suicider
parmi ses publications figurent aussi
les appels à se suicider datant du 3
mars dernier
comme vous le savez il ya eu plusieurs
tentatives de suicide parmi des enfants
qui ont heureusement échoué
bonnet a sonné bon ça papotait gasquet
seulement 8,4 et de notre part nous
avons été témoins de l'ignorance
manifeste de twitter à l'égard des
demandes de notre société de supprimer
ces appels quant au trésor de façon plus
générale les autorités russes demandent
davantage de modération dans les
contenus publiés par lé géant des
réseaux sociaux
le kremlin avait par exemple dénoncé les
appels à manifester en soutien à l'excès
navalni des appels diffusés en début
d'année sur ces plateformes anormal que
les rassemblements en question était
interdit de l'adsa on reproche à ces
réseaux sociaux en russie de fonctionner
en dehors de tout cadre juridique et
donc de ne pas obéir aux différentes
lois de la russie au final tout est une
question d'équilibré entre accès à
l'information et respect de la loi comme
l'a résumé le porte-parole du kremlin
vous voyez les citoyens russes doivent
bien sûr avoir la possibilité d'accéder
à toutes les bourses mondiales
c'est le but principal mais à part ça la
fonction de supervision consiste à
assurer que toutes ces sources agissent
dans le cadre juridique qu'elle respecte
la loi et se conforment aux exigences
légitimes des autorités russes sur le
territoire de la fédération de russie
donc personne n'a aucune envie de
bloquer quoi que ce soit mais c'est à
juste titre que nous prenons des mesures
visant à forcer ses entreprises à
répondre aux exigences de notre loi à
l'heure actuelle il ne s'agit que d'un
ralentissement du flux de twitter mais
si un accord n'est pas conclu
il pourrait être question d'un blocage
pur et sain et il existe des précédents
le réseau social professionnel linkedin
est bloqué et donc indisponibles sur
l'internet russe depuis plus de quatre
ans maintenant
l'entreprise américaine ayant refusé de
stocker les données des utilisateurs
russes sur des serveurs localisés en
russie ont coûté la réaction d'andré
walker et les commentateurs politiques
et chroniqueur
tout d'abord je tiens à condamner cette
décision je ne pense pas que ce soit
juste de restreindre la liberté
d'expression d'une telle manière
j'éprouve quand même beaucoup de
sympathie pour les autorités russes si
tout simplement de l'hypocrisie twitter
et les sociétés comme facebook se
plaignent constamment d'être impuissante
face aux problèmes liés aux violations
de la loi et de leurs propres conditions
d'utilisation quand il s'agit de crimes
mais dès qu'il s'agit de politique
elles sont parfaitement heureuse
intervenir sur le plan politique je
tiens à vous donner un exemple classique
quand le comportement de hunter maiden a
été exposée sur twitter parce qu'il
avait laissé son ordinateur dans un
atelier de réparation et qu'il ya eu une
fuite de certaines informations
twitter a limité leur diffusion parce
qu'il y avait une règle selon laquelle
on ne pouvait pas diffuser des
informations piratées
ce qui semblait raisonnable un peu plus
tard quelqu'un a publié les déclarations
d'impôts de donald trump qui avait
manifestement été volés au gouvernement
américain
twitter a décidé que c'était acceptable
j'estime que ce qui révolte les gens à
cet égard c'est l'hypocrisie absolue
c'est ce que je déteste dans tout cela
je comprends que le gouvernement russe
se sentent indigné parce que voilà ce
qui se produit je comprends que le
gouvernement russe se sont indignés
parce que voilà ce qui se produit toute
attaque contre la russie est autorisé et
tous les défenseurs de la russie sont
réduits au silence
comment les gens ne serait-il pas
révoltés dans une telle situation
et pour terminer cette émission
direction le yémen pays vous savez
plongé dans la guerre depuis 2014
l'espoir d'une fin des hostilités dont
l'esprit de nombreux habitants
illustration chérel lastras notamment
reconstituer la capitale sanaa
hohmeister le récit de capital c'est
avec un taux de cartons de coller de
peinture comme ochir saison a donné
forme à sa ville idéale celle qu'il
espère pouvoir retrouver une fois que la
guerre au yémen sera terminée depuis
apprise de sanaa par les outils fin 2014
la capitale yéménite est fréquemment
frappée par les bombardements de la
coalition militaire conduite par
l'arabie saoudite
des raids aériens menés contre des
infrastructures civiles dont des
hôpitaux des pièces centrales de la
maquette de mourir ce qui me motive pour
faire ça ce sont les conséquences de la
guerre qui a frappé le pays en termes de
destruction des bâtiments
j'essaie de leur montrer comment
reconstruire une salle à ma manière
une passion née chez l'adolescent il y a
6 ans au début de la guerre aujourd'hui
mme ochir espère en faire son métier et
aider à la reconstruction de son pays
facal à madame chazal je lui ai demandé
d'améliorer encore ses compétences et
d'affiner son talent afin de faire
avancer son ambition de faire quelque
chose de plus grand comme la conception
de grands bâtiments et d'institutions
pour qu'il passe à l' architecture mais
l'heure n'est pas encore à la
reconstruction
il ya quelques jours de nouveaux raids
aériens visant les outils ont été menées
sur la capitale sanaa les premiers
depuis des mois la guerre au yémen a
fait des dizaines de milliers de morts
selon plusieurs ong internationales
entraînant la pire crise humanitaire
actuelle selon l'onu c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
dans quelques minutes avec pierre et sa
vie et vers le haut
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répond en appartement on est énervé
donnait le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
au loin de paris mais toujours moins de
ce qu'il est guéri
moi j'en ai marre qu'on les fasse un
tour de tracteur avec nous suivrons
campagne il faut savoir c'est qu'une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soi vient des
lignes ans
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
tous les prêts moins de notre époque
sont dans la grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]